okay
so hi guys um today we are going to be
presenting on
visualizing the topic progression of a
text my name is lainey moy
um when i participated in the wolf
emerging leaders program last fall
i was a senior at thomas jefferson high
school for science and technology
i'm currently a freshman at the
university of illinois at
urbana-champaign studying computer
science
i'm also working at wolfram research as
an intern in the document and media
systems department
and i was a ta at the wolfram summer
camp this past summer
hi i'm richard gupta and i'm a senior at
the illinois math and science academy
i presented a poster at last year's
wolfram tech conference and i was an
interviewer for the wolf of tech talks
i'm excited to be here again
uh hi my name is alex alexandrovsky i
was a
student at wolfgang summer camp in 2019
at ta
uh in the canberra 2020 and i also
participated in wealth last year
um so our our project is basically on
determining the topic progression of a
text and as you can see in this visual
um here we have the axis of time and
here we have like the percentage of the
conversation so this is one of our final
results
um and you can see that a lot of the
conversation is taken up by this
topic and later by this topic so we'll
talk about all this later in our
presentation
um but after attending the vulcan summer
camp two years ago
in 2019 we were part of the wolf
emerging leaders program
under the mentorship of rory folger who
is lovely as they will
as a wolf emerging leaders program
project team we created a tool to
summarize and present the structure
of a complex piece of natural language
and graphical form by identifying the
dominant topics
within the text and visualizing their
progression we use a simple clustering
algorithm to assign words to topics
based on their distributions in the text
and we feed the resulting data into a
number of different visualization
functions
effectively providing a semantic
overview of the text our methods could
be applied to long-form writing such as
novels articles or textbooks as well as
transcripts or
of audio recordings like podcasts
lectures and meetings
so the objective of our project was to
identify and visualize topic progression
of a text
we originally intended for it to be a
tool for students to review major ideas
but it can be extended for anything from
a podcast to a novel
in order to identify the topics we
clustered words from the text based on
the distribution of their frequency
in relation to each other once we had
the clusters of free
wednesday the clusters of related words
we filter the clusters using a variety
of hyper parameters
and thresholds for meaningful topics
then we created visualizations using
those topics
uh so our first sort of task was uh
trying to figure out how to
um found out find out and sort of um
build our topics and we researched uh a
number of solutions for that
specifically
um lda lsa and lda with um
conjunction with um word to back uh and
so lda and lsa
are their
methods for
matching topics uh between documents um
and that sort of in conjunction with
word effect
adds uh the dimension of the meaning of
the word um
and uh how close the mimi's words are uh
and so on and
um eventually we decided to uh
not go that route and to build our own
algorithm basically
based on distributions of words uh more
than
um meaning of words because we realize
that there are certain cases where
words with the same topic uh can
obviously words uh with very different
meanings can very obviously be part of
the same topics
yeah for example if you're looking at um
uh
this is uh alice in wonderland the text
of alice in wonderland and
the histograms are basically the um
the bars are occurrences of two words in
the text so the left one is taurt and
the right one is court
uh and those words obviously have very
different meaning but they're part of
the same
section the book and the same uh we
would consider the same topic
um and and that's why we we decided to
go with um
distribution based atomic modeling
solution
um so we start off with our hyper
parameters which allow us to approximate
um how we're going to go about our
algorithm so our first hyper parameter
is word num fraction
um and this is the approximately the
number of
um words out of the total unique words
that we're going to consider as possibly
part of a topic
so um we came up with about 8.3 of the
total unique words will be associated
with the topic
um and this may like vary depending on
the granularity that
um the user is looking for um but this
is a number
that we found worked well and then topic
number fraction
is relative to the number of words that
you're considering
how many topics um might exist
and this is all before we start
filtering um
and then max word standard deviation we
use to
prevent words that appear frequently
throughout the text so
for instance in alice in wonderland
which we're using as our example here
um the word alice likely appears
throughout the text and shouldn't be
associated with a single topic
so we're saying that if the standard
deviation of a single word is greater
than
uh 25 of the length of the text then we
don't consider it
and max topic fraction is similar we
don't want general topics that last
more than 30 of the length of the text
so these hyper parameters we just found
worked well in this
scenario in the future we could change
them or update them based on the
granularity
that we were looking for in a specific
text
so for selecting words we first take the
text of alice in wonderland which we got
from the welcome data repository
um and then we
remove all the punctuation and put
everything in lowercase
and then we use word stems for um
instead of actual words because we want
to consider
like run and running as part of the same
topic um
and we'd want to count them together so
we
words them slash at the brawlest and
then
the number of words that we're looking
for is the same as
our word number fraction times the
length of the initial list
only counting distinct words and
topic num is word number which we
calculated here
times the topic number fraction so then
in multiple lists we remove all of the
words that only appear once
and from here we remove all of the words
that
have a standard deviation greater than
the max word standard deviation
multiplied by the length of the um of
the list or of the text
um and then we take the word and most
common words of those and these are the
words we're going to move forward with
for considering topics
uh so for um our actual algorithm of
topic clustering what we did was um we
found
for each uh each of the words that we
selected uh
the mean position in the text and the uh
variance of the position in the text uh
and
um essentially we took those two
dimensions and uh sort of
plotted them you could say and then um
try to find um clusters within that
so like sets of points where uh they
have about the same mean about the same
uh variance uh and so you could possibly
say they're
part of the same topic uh and um
we um if you scroll down a little bit
yeah so um after that uh you know
if you um when you run the um
like fine clusters function that wolfram
has uh
the results um like are still
rough and you have to filter them so for
example uh
using the bounds function which is
basically just the um
it finds the uh the one of the first
occurrences
uh of um a a word that is part of a
given topic and one of the last to the
like 10th and 90th percentile
uh by you know position uh
um and if if um
sort of the the range of uh the topic is
too large
um then we remove that because it's if
it's essentially a topic that
spans the entire text then it's kind of
useless to
um you know consider us and similarly we
also remove
uh words that uh have too high of a
variance
um and uh because you know they're
they're mostly
uh also kind of uses this uh and
uh you know using um using that if you
plot uh
the clusters that we end up with this is
uh what it looks like so the different
colors are
different clusters
uh and the final step here is to
uh label the topics and we want the
labels to just be the
list of words um inside of a topic
and um but right now we're operating
with word stamps so we just
look for a noun in the text that
corresponds to one of the word stamps
and
replace that and use that as our label
so um now that we have the
uh methodology and approach covered we
can see how successful our
visualizations were
so our first visualization was just a
very basic flow chart
it shows the general order of topics but
it doesn't show frequency duration or
importance of the topics in any way um
in order to make it if you look at the
code here we just built a table of
association of rules
we connected each topic with the
following topic and then used a layered
graph plot to visualize that table
this visualization is great for quick
review and it's easily readable
but it didn't show a lot of information
but it was a great starting point for us
next visualization that we made was the
timeline chart
this chart showcases the duration of
each topic which can be used to estimate
the prevalence of the topic in the text
as a whole
while this visualization shows more than
the flow chart
it is still lacking in some areas for
example it doesn't incorporate the
frequency of each topic
so when topics are occupying the same
duration you have no way of knowing
which one is dominant or more frequent
um in order to make this visualization
we need a table of the intervals for
each cluster
which was determined based on the 10th
and 90th percentile of appearances
for each word in the topic which we used
which was represented by the function
bounds which we explained earlier
we then visualize that table using
number line plot
and here is it for alice in wonderland
um our next visualization is the
frequency chart visualization which
provides more insight into the actual
distribution of topics within the text
um so if you recall we talked about um
earlier using tart and court and we saw
that they were like located in similar
positions
so we do that again with all of the
words that are in clusters
um so each bar here each vertical bar
represents
an occurrence of a word and then the
color of the bar
indicates which topic that
word corresponds to so there
are a couple issues with this one as
well it's hard to see like
where specifically in the text they
occur or
sometimes it's hard to tell how much
each topic is talked about and dominant
topics also block
out less dominant topics but you can see
we have a progression from like
the dark purple through the lighter
purple into some
green we've got some orange stripes in
here and then over at the end we have
some blue and gray as well
um this our next visualization is our
stacked area plot visualization which
shows the frequency at which a topic
occurs relative to time
so it displays both how much and for how
long a topic appears in the text
so first what we do is we create our
list of all of the words that appear in
clusters
and then from our list of all the words
in the text
we select all the ones that are in
clusters
so then our cluster id list is the
list of positions within all cluster
words
for each um word in initialist cluster
and then cluster association points from
um each of the words in all cluster
words
um well the position of
each word in all cluster words and to
the cluster that we're looking for
so then um cluster ids will
give us a list of the id numbers for
each word
in initial list cluster that correspond
to a specific topic
so then we can know um which topic
each of these words belongs to
so then um here basically what we're
doing is we're taking the derivative at
a point
um and we're using num 10 as in we're
considering
each um we're considering the word that
we're on and the following 10
words and um
for these ten words we count how many of
them
are in each topic um and then based on
that we form
our like our y list which is
um the like stacked
list of how um
um yeah of how much
of the conversation is dedicated to each
topic
um and here we can see it's kind of
jagged
um our visualization here
right so what we do next is we
use bezier curves to smooth it out a bit
this is completely
optional and you don't have to do it
just to make it look a little prettier
um and then when we show them on top of
each other you can see
here we have a little like there's some
talk about feeling marked which is a bit
of an ambiguous name but
um you can see that's the introduction
as she enters wonderland and then
talking about this section and over at
the end you get
um some about the kings and this is the
the yellow part is the queen of hearts
section you may recall
so all the visualizations up until this
point were sort of
um uh external to the text
uh and this one is the only one where
you can actually see sort of
the topics um in the text uh so this is
meant to color
uh the text based on um you know which
topics
um it's currently uh about
uh so uh basically first
uh we assign certain colors to um topics
and then
um so we we look at the text and say
that
so all the words that are already part
of a certain topic
uh we color them to call that topic but
then for the words that are in between
them
uh if a section is in between two words
of the same topic
uh we obviously color it um the same
color
uh as that topic uh but for cases where
um uh if there's a section that is in
between
two uh topic words that are of different
topics
what we do is uh we look at all the
topics and calculate
um the their mean position in the text
so look at all of the occurrences of all
the words inside them
and get the mean position and then for
um those sections that are sort of
undecided
we look at uh from the middle of that
section and we see
which of the topic means it's closest to
uh and from there we um color it
that color and that's basically
uh how the algorithm works uh and
uh so for um the result if you scroll
down a little bit
uh it's it's unfortunately um
there's like too much data to be uh fit
into like an outlet but there's
um a picture here of what it kind of
looks like
as you can see at the start um it's blue
then brown
blue again and so on this large cross
section you can kind of see
um you know there's little sprinkles of
uh
topics inside other topics and uh that's
that's kind of uh i feel can can have
some sort of value in
understanding how the tech sort of flows
yeah oh sorry now we've gone through
explaining everything let's see how
some examples of how our topic model
actually works so
we've been using alice in wonderland as
an example throughout the uh
the talk so here's a compilation of the
topic progression visualizations for
that text
as you can see some of the words in each
topic are very clearly linked to one
another
such as kings and majesty or queen and
hearts
and queen and hearts are linked together
because of the namesake character who
predominantly shows up in that part of
the text
uh the first topic feeling marked is a
little bit more ambiguous
but it's as you can see from like where
it shows up in the timeline chart
it's obviously about alice entering
wonderline
which wonderland which is why it shows
up in the beginning
um in the frequency start you can see
how some topics show up multiple times
such as the orange near 6000 words or
the brown near the end and that's
something that would only be shown in
the frequency chart and the stack area
plot
not in the timeline chart um the stacked
area plot
shows how all these topics relate to
each other with duration and
frequency etc overall the actual topics
seem to be consistent and representative
of the text
even if some topic titles are slightly
ambiguous
um the example of alice in wonderland
can showcase how our program functions
for fictional texts in general
so we ran the program again for a
peer-reviewed article entitled the
socio-economic implications of the
coronavirus pandemic
which was written by marie nicola at all
we chose this text because we were
curious about how the program would work
for non-fiction informational texts
and um you can see that most of the
topics are very clear-cut
and obviously related such as research
conferences
domestic abuse mortgage house etc there
are also some like japan loan scheme
and oil saudi prices where the topic
tiles are more specific
but you can still see that they're
related to each other in the frequency
chart
you can see blocks of each color which
is a good sign and it makes sense
because
in a research paper especially this one
specifically
topics will be more separated than in a
fictional text
um the stacked area plot is a little bit
different from the alice in wonderland
one because it has more variety in the
curves
you can see where different topics exist
simultaneously whereas for alice in
wonderland
it was a little bit more diagonal
overall this example showcases
how our program can function
successfully for informational texts as
in addition to fictional texts
so in conclusion we successfully
identified and filtered topic clusters
and we created five visualizations for
varying purposes and those would be the
flowchart timeline chart frequency chart
stack area plot and color-coded text
in the future we'd like to allow the
same word to be part of two distinct
topics and we'd also like to
build something that allows for bimodal
topics that occur multiple times
throughout the text
we'd also like to apply our project to
audio clips of conversations and
lectures
um and create a cloud application with
user options to alter the hyper
parameters so that a user could
upload a text and determine their
desired granularity
we'd also like to contribute this to the
wolfram function repository
we would like to thank rory folger the
wolf emerging leaders program
coordinator and william goodall the
assistant coordinator
as well as all the other participants
and the vote for events team for putting
together this conference
thank you so much if you have any
questions you can drop them in the past
full chat
um yeah so i'm gonna upload the notebook
as soon as we finish here
um thank you
if anybody has questions about like our
backgrounds as well or wants to see the
visualizations again we can totally go
through that
oh um rodrigo i'm not sure that i
understand your question
um would you like to unmute yourself
and ask
hi lenny can you hear me uh yes i can
hear you
hi nice first of all nice presentation
and i'd like to know if you you plan to
to do some like a neural net before to
do this team
because like birds you can get paired
the concepts
yes and maybe in instead of a simple
steam
put another layer in the top of that i
don't know if you have training or do
something like that
as an experiment yeah so we definitely
thought about
using neural networks in some way to um
either
come up with the topics or figure out
what hyper parameters work best
um and that's something we totally
consider doing in the future
okay cool
okay so since it doesn't look like there
are any more questions
um well we'd like to thank you for
coming listen to us talk
um we had a lot of fun with this project
and we hope that you enjoyed
our final product um
we can drop our emails in the chat if
any of you would like to um
ask us any more questions
um thank you so much
you